- [Narrator] Both of its wings
have transparent windows.
- Crystal duck.
(audience laughing)
- Open the Southern border.
(voices overlapping)
- Care about now more coronavirus cases
than any single country in the world.
(voices rapidly overlapping)
- NFTs are.
(rapid gunfire)
(voices chaotically overlapping)
- The leak is not our main concern, is it?
- [Joey] I feel like I wanna
jump out of my own skin.
- I just
- [Joey] That's the type of thought
that runs through my brain
when I feel overloaded, overstimulated,
when I'm jacked in.
Keeping up with every
little thing that's going on
in the world, it's like a pressure,
a tension.
- No, no, no, no.
- [Joey] Caving in my skull.
- That's good, just
keep rubbing your head.
- I nurse on the input, like a newborn.
It's the first thing I
reach for when I wake,
the last thing I look at before I sleep.
And yeah, I know it's not good.
I'd rather be doing something
else, but I can't help
but feel that if I let it
go, I'll miss something.
I'll feel disconnected, alone.
But the pressure builds.
This extension of myself.
It revs my mind up and it doesn't stop.
It's like I'm looking for something.
(birds chirping)
One thing that I've started to notice
is that whenever I cut
myself off from the feed,
when I choose to be alone,
when I seek stillness,
I find it.
And this feeling I was running from
was what I was searching for.
Life is often exactly as
simple as we need it to be.
There's nothing complicated
about a flowing stream,
a crackling fire, a cloudy day.
Unless of course we make it that way.
We can always analyze
life, cerebralize it,
theorize about it if we need to.
But how often do we need to?
Are things not also
meant to be experienced
for what they are, as they are?
Because, obviously thinking about things
and analyzing reality
helps us understand it.
But when we live in our
heads, it distorts reality.
We start looking with our
minds instead of our eyes.
The mountains don't care
what we think of them.
(wind howling)
(raindrops tapping)
There's a quote by GK Chesterton
that's always stuck
with me, goes like this.
"It is an act of faith to
assert that our thoughts
"have any relation to reality at all.
"If you're merely a skeptic,
"you must sooner or later
ask yourself the question.
"Why should anything go right,
"even observation and deduction?
"Why should not good logic be
as misleading as bad logic.
"They are both movements in
the brain of a bewildered ape."
I always thought this
quote was pretty funny
and it does a great job of
reminding us that what happens
inside our brains may
not be as sophisticated
as we probably think.
We tend to celebrate the human mind
as the pinnacle of intelligence.
Yet, when we spend too much time in there,
we become anxious and isolated.
Why is that?
Why is it that the most
common piece of advice
that you might hear for
someone who's socially anxious,
needlessly vengeful, or
compulsively conspiratorial
is get outta your head.
It's like we all instinctively know
that there's a disconnect
between reality itself
and our interpretation of it.
And when we spend too much
time untethered from the world
as it is, and instead
filter our experiences
through references and
distortions, isn't it obvious
that the resulting
effect is disorientation?
Is it not obvious that
when we plug ourselves
into sources that profit off
stirring up fear and dread
within us, that we would feel
more worried and dreadful.
I always find it hilarious.
It'll be a beautiful day
outside, the most peaceful,
divine reality before us
but we'll be on YouTube
or Twitter or Reddit.
and there'll be some
world event that usually
has nothing to do with us
and we'll go, that's terrible.
Man, the world is (beep) up.
And then we look out the
window at the glorious sun
piercing through the clouds
over a rolling landscape
and instead of wonder,
or awe, or gratitude,
we think, would I
survive a nuclear winter?
I'll leave you guys with a quote.
Marcus Aurelius said
that if you're distressed
by anything external, the pain is not due
to the thing itself but
to your estimate of it
and this you have the power
to revoke at any moment.
Yeah, I'm feeling really good guys.
Honestly, I feel like there's
a one-to-one relationship
between my mental health and
the amount of time I spend
on social media or just like
in front of any kind of screen
for any reason whatsoever.
It always pays off to just spend time away
from my computer, from my phone.
And recently I've been going
to the gym way more often.
I've been spending time
outside and I've really started
to just nail simple daily habits
that make me feel really good
and a habit that's been
extremely important in my life
over the past, like two years or so
is also the sponsor of today's video
and that is taking Athletic Greens.
A big thank you to Athletic Greens
for sponsoring this video.
As I've talked about before,
I've been taking Athletic
Greens for like two years now
and I actually reached out to them
and asked them if they
want to be a sponsor
of this channel because I
take their stuff every day.
And it's a huge contributor
to my overall physical and mental health
because there's basically
no competing with the amount
of vitamins and nutrients
that are absolutely jam packed
into one scoop of this stuff.
There are 75 vitamins, minerals,
whole foods sourced
super foods, probiotics,
and adaptogens in one
convenient daily serving.
AG1 supports your energy,
focus, gut health, digestion,
immunity, and mental
clarity without the need
to take multiple products or pills.
Athletic Greens uses these
whole foods and natural sources
and condenses them into this fine powder,
which you scoop up, you add
to water and you drink it.
And I've tried so many
different greens, powders,
and potions and weird stuff over the years
and out of all of them, this
one by far tastes the best.
So, it's just a very pleasant
way to start off your morning
with the confidence that
you're giving your body
all the tools that it needs
to be filled with energy
and to perform optimally
throughout the day.
So, if you're interested in joining me
in this very simple daily
health optimization habit
which I've been partaking
in for about two years now,
use my link in the description below
and you'll also get a year's
supply of the vitamin D3
and K2 complex which I also use
every single morning, as
well as five AG1 travel packs
with your first purchase.
So once again, if you're
interested in AG1,
use my link in the description
below to get a year supply
of the vitamin D3 and K2 complex
as well as five AG1 travel
packs with your first purchase.
Thanks again, Athletic Greens
for sponsoring this video.
And if you like this video, make sure
that you actually hit the like button
because when you hit the like button,
the algorithm blesses me
by shoving my bald head
into other people's
homepages, helping them out
which also helps me out.
So, it's just a win-win for everybody
if you just click that like button.
And if you're lurking
here, consider subscribing
and checking out the second channel,
which has been fairly inactive as of late,
but I post some goodies
on there sometimes.
I'll also be releasing the
fact that I got a PO Box
and I know some people
wanna send me some stuff
and I'll do an unboxing on
there and it'll be super fun.
So yeah, just subscribe
to the second channel
to stay tuned for that.
Other than that, thank
you so much for watching.
Go touch grass and I'll
catch you in the next video.